[Musique]
c'est fait le canada officiellement
jouer lire à des pays signataires du
protocole de kyoto 300 millions
d'européens vivent aujourd'hui une
expérience unique le passage à une
monnaie commune dans une douzaine de
pays
le vrai test pour l'euro aura lieu
demain toujours no 10 l'euro est là en a
pas on n'a pas retenu les militaires
sont tous sortis l'aéroport l'un
derrière l'autre pour monter à bord d'un
airbus a310 des forces armées
canadiennes en chemin vers un vol de 19
heures qui va les mener quelque part
dans le golfe arabo persique
c'est une mission beaucoup plus
périlleuse que celle qui était prévu à
l'origine
la crise au proche orient continue de
s'aggraver d'heure en heure
ce soir c'est le tour de la ville
autonome de jénine en cisjordanie d'être
investi par les chars israéliens
cela a commencé comme une simple soirée
au théâtre
une comédie musicale à guichets fermés
mais la soirée a tourné à la tragédie
lorsqu'une cinquantaine de rebelles
armés a fait irruption sur la scène et
s'est mis à tirer en l'air au procès de
maurice boucher le verdict est
finalement tombé coupable
l'avocat de la défense jacques
larochelle lui est sorti sans accorder
d'entrevue il faut d'abord que la
défense obtiennent l'autorisation d'en
appeler ça ce sera entendue vendredi
matin en cour d'appel
[Musique]
c'est important parce que la visite de
la reine donne de la visibilité ou
nunavut dieu protège les inuits ont fait
brûler le feu symbolique qui rassemble
les 50 ans du règne d'elizabeth deux
sont synonyme de changement gagnant
ça a été le sujet du jour tout le monde
en parle c'est l'indignation total on
parle littéralement de vol de médailles
2e
[Applaudissements]